almost everyone's been stuck in
unrequited love at some point and some
of us are happy to stay there there's no
risk of being dumped if you pined from
afar no chance of bickering no in-laws
no breakups another big tick in a plus
column is that the object of your
affections can be the most perfect being
that ever existed they're not really of
course but if you're not required you
can't be disappointed by their morning
breath their poor communication skills
or they're obnoxious political views to
be required to this to put yourself at
risk to jump and hope for the best to be
unrequited is to be safe wrapped up in
an adult-sized comfort blanket with a
big tub of chocolate chips self-pity
people often insist you must tell them
how you feel when they really mean you
must learn to do with rejection and you
must grow up because when it comes down
to it the problem is not that they don't
love you it's that you don't love you
you think they don't notice you and yet
they're worth all this angst but if
someone can't see the love that's in
front of them they're an idiot worse if
they see it and don't mind that you're
upset they're cruel so get out of bed
stop wasting your time don't spend a
minute more of your life dreaming about
someone who must be a cruel idiot and
you can't possibly be all you imagine
them to be if they don't love you
already
that's Varys I think you're great
you